hey this is John Delaney again with my
good friend Rachael Cruz wearing the
same clothes
Korona why not right so I don't talk
about today is this idea of super woowoo
people think it's cheesy and ridiculous
this idea of gratitude and so we can't
leave the house except for this we're 6
feet apart these are just lenses that
make us look like really close for
actually 6 to 7 feet apart right now we
can't even change our clothes what are
we what are we doing about gratitude
right now like how are we remaining
grateful in this season yeah well we
kind of talked about it on another video
but for me personally I just said this
is so short term like this is gonna be
ending this whole quarantine thing and
even the economy I think we're gonna
we're gonna come out of it it's gonna
get back health stuff you know maybe
they'll find a cure I don't know like
it's like I just believe in our world
enough to know like we're gonna come out
of this so in the time being like just
knowing that it's short term like this
is not gonna be for the next six years
of our lives that this is like how we're
gonna be living so that's kind of what I
focus on if like okay I mean I feel like
I can be grateful for like all the
random things because I know like those
random things are probably not gonna be
happening and then I in six months from
now do you is graduating that you
practice on the regs or is it like just
a disposition that you have do it no I
mean I practice that for sure like
riding down a few things every morning
that I'm grateful for and I did that
better in routine or out of routine
because there weren't a but but no that
is like a discipline that I have yeah
because it is it's just true I'm like
when you just goes from me for so long I
woke up I grabbed my phone and like
checked email and all but you know I
mean like that you just start off my day
like that and like and you know that's
probably better than I even do but the
science even if your brain of like what
gratitude does to you and I can
experience that firsthand like I know
what that feels like and the changes and
Who I am when you're grateful cuz when
you're not grateful and you are in a
hard season for me I can go back to that
list and just see like pages and pages
and pages and have anything on my Notes
app so I'm like I can just scroll scroll
just listed the most random things that
I've wrote written you know throughout
the past couple years of things I'm
grateful for so that's helped me a lot
and so you go back and review those yeah
Tom's your house up a gratitude practice
or is this just something you do by
yourself
uh no it's kinda something I just do
your husband's
great yeah he's not grateful don't
believe this guy
um so here's how you actually brought
mine this is ax this is like my I bought
it at like a coffee shop this is like
fireflies at some old TV show but it's
like a TV show diary but like this is it
man this is like the one I actually use
and I'm getting to the very end of it
and then this is like this is my day and
I carry this card around I don't have
like a notes a print act that I'm not
savvy enough for that but I actually
write it down every day do you have a
journaling practice that you use yes
tell me about that I'm and I'll say this
I'm very seasonal with my journal he's
like author college i journaled like
almost every day okay
and then I mean I've had like ups and
downs throughout like being out when I
was in college it was like four years of
straight and I wish I I wish I kept it
up because I can go back to those right
like you couldn't call honors it
dramatic it's a little dramatic but you
know I do have do you know what I do
have done true story in my freshman year
journal it was like gosh it had to have
been I mean school starts by October or
August those probably said tomorrow's
really early on when I was six I was a
crime on my dorm the first day I met
Winston Cruz I wrote in my journal Oh
gross I said God if I could marry a man
like what's the crew that would be so
amazing I thought he was so hot it was
like all the things and I was like I
have that written is that not funny and
then two years later he asked me out
know I like to say that I'm like it's
crazy like going back and you read like
good times bad times in your life off
your journal it's just so helpful with
perspective and then for me in this
recent season I've been hurling a ton
because I just have like I don't know
things are changing in my heart and
different things but I'm like it's good
just to document it when you get it out
and it's not just floating in your head
it's such a good practice how do you
recommend people around you who maybe
aren't disposed to gratitude like you
are don't have effective practices what
do you tell folks gosh I would say that
we have like 11 trillion followers on
your social medias and the Internet's
it's really what do you tell them I mean
for me gratitude when it comes like even
just the money message
I mean it's like the Gateway to
contentment and so when you're grateful
when you have a heart filled with
gratitude there's no room for
discontentment in comparisons all of
these like enemies that attack us in so
many ways gratitude just takes that all
out to love contentment I believe so yes
so I have a contentment Journal speaking
of journaling so I love drawings you've
read my own so the contentment journal
so it walks through all like these steps
basically of how to become content so it
actually starts with gratitude leads to
humility which leads to contentment so I
have 30 days three days of each of those
because they're big segments right big
words but once you can practice someone
get them in a rhythm it changes you but
we I start with gratitude in it because
it's huge so I wanna just like come up
with this crazy scenario let's say
you've got I'm just gonna make this up
totally I'm so nervous you got let's say
to parents who have kind of been who
they've been for a long time and they
may or may not be super outspoken about
what they believe and they think and
then how do you encourage them to be
grateful I mean I would say starting
just with yourself cuz I think it
becomes really vulnerable if you're not
used to sharing on that level and like
just doing it it can be very vulnerable
if you haven't done it yourself so I
would recommend practicing it yourself
so just like writing it down they're
putting it at your nuts app keeping it
to yourself for a little bit it's okay
cuz you're practicing it yourself I love
it how to feel it and then from that
when you be not becomes normalized I
feel like it's easier than to
communicate that to someone else awesome
and communicating gratitude [ __ ] he
can't be vulnerable but it doesn't be
scary like you're not communicating
conflict or like mm something a big
topic right like it's much like with
your spouse okay good just like I'm
really grateful for our light fixture
that I picked out last year I love it
like no you're the daughter and can
start kind of shallow and the deaths so
yeah so here's a couple things I think's
critical that I've learned about
gratitude number one is when when
something bad happens right and the
buzzword around that right now is trauma
when something traumatic happens to you
whether it's it's affirmative trauma
which like you saw a car wreck or you
had an abusive relationship or something
is no
affirmative trauma like you were
neglected as a kid or your parents were
never around they are working too much
whatever and that you you grow up with
that disconnection that doesn't have a
clock or a calendar on it and what's so
beautiful about gratitude is it brings
you to the right now does that make
sense yeah grateful for this thing today
yeah and it takes you from your your
traumatic response from your living
system to your I'm here right now and
right I just you just nailed the process
from gratitude to contentment but I like
to think of gratitude I mean as
contentment as this how my shoulders
just dropped like I'm here does that
make sense there's a piece and say yeah
this practice and so I want to recommend
everybody do two things number one
whether you may or may not take a small
booklet from the place that you work and
hopefully they don't it's not stealing
is it you start a new journal during a
tough season so when Corona kicked off
March 29th that's when I started this
thing and I'm an introvert from Texas I
got a lifetime hunting pass for the
state of Texas my dad's a homicide
detective like I'm a consider myself
like a poseur tough guy and yet I know
that every morning I'm waking up and I'm
writing down my feelings a couple days
ago I woke up with I'm scared today
today my feelings started with the first
line is I'm feeling lonely more so every
passing day and it's important for me to
get that out of my head and out here and
on paper so then it becomes tangible and
now I can sit about solving it instead
of just spinning around in my head right
and the second thing is make a plan and
again I'm lo-fi and I carry this around
in my pocket with me and it's got like
go for a walk and the rain said X was
raining this morning a few my gratitude
journal through my prayers I even put
hugs my family cuz I get busy and I get
up in my head and I forget to engage
with my family but make a new plan every
day that's the other thing about our
heads man is familiar equals safety in
our brains right so everything around us
is screwed up and everything is
unfamiliar so every one of our alarms
has gone off and so the quicker we can
get back on a routine even if the only
routine you have is making a new routine
Yeah right it does yes it brings respect
to the
now okay before we go yeah one thing
you're grateful for one thing I'm writ
for in the crazy of Corona trademark
it's kind of broad but it's just true my
family right now like being home with my
kids that's been so fun
I've really enjoyed it yes they're like
I don't know we've kind of gotten in a
new routine I'm like oh well like this
is fun being with them and like doing
naps and all of it being there for all
of it
in Winstead of course my husband um I'm
actually grateful for my wife first I am
grateful for the same thing for this
season of closeness and togetherness
yeah I can't imagine us know where we
ever have this again totally and so as
mind numbing or as bananas as it can be
it's also such a gift
right I mean I was talking to Dave the
other day about I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to go back to work without
five hug breaks this day right and just
the planing with with Sheila every day
my wife every day he has what Stacy look
like so um it's cool season is a wild
season for sure stay grateful make a
plan every day make me intentionally be
grateful yeah and this is John DeLorean
my good for Rachel Cruz signing out
rock on to the bring it on